ladies and gentlemen good morning
welcome at the Press briefing and the
two statements for media at the occasion
of the visit of the president of the
European commission urusola from The
Lion uh first let me give the photo to
the Prime Minister Patrick fiala well
ladies and gentlemen good morning
I am happy thereafter sometime I again
had a chance to welcome the president of
the European commission here in Prague
and I'm glad that apart from being
together at the morning conference we
had a chance to have a working meeting
here at the office of the government
and we had a chance to discuss important
topics important not only for Europe but
also for my government
we have discussed a number of issues
starting with energy and also searching
on migration and I'll mention some of
those topics to more detail
I reminded the president of the European
commission that
nuclear energy is really important for
the Czech Republic It's a traditional
industrial sector for our country we
have many experts in our country and at
our universities and it's also one of
the ways for our country to achieve the
climate objectives and to have
sufficient sources of energy so that's
why it is important that nuclear energy
remains one of the preferred sources of
energy clean energy in the Czech
Republic
and we're doing our best so that nuclear
energy stays the accepted source of
energy
we also talked with the president about
the current state of affairs so when it
comes to our tender for building new
units in nuclear power plant in dukovani
so we're still waiting to evaluate the
bids and we also discussed the process
how to notify the European Commission
because that is a must of course
we will need nuclear energy in the Czech
Republic in the future we will need new
units and we're also open to new
technologies such as small modular
reactors
so from this perspective the completion
of the notification process is a huge
priority for us and I'm happy that after
today's discussions with the president
I can see that there is a chance that we
succeed with the notification process
we also talked about another project
that is important for energy security of
the Czech Republic and to finally get
rid of the Russian fossil fuels for good
and that's the tal plus oil pipeline
we've already taken a number of steps
and we need the final consent of the
European Commission
of course we we haven't discussed only
energy even though energy of course is a
key topic for the future of Europe the
future of the Czech Republic it's
important for our country's
competitiveness but we also talked about
other challenges and hot issues in
Europe at present for example the
current migration crisis
be it migration coming from the south
but also
how we dealt with that huge number of
refugees coming to us from Ukraine
Ukraine which suffers on the Russian
aggression
the Czech Republic when it comes to
discussions about migration policy is
convinced that it is better and it is
important to protect the external
borders of the European Union to
decrease the number of economic refugees
it is better to do it on the border
rather than deal with it than inside the
European Union we are ready to
participate in protecting the external
borders our objective is to stop people
from getting on the journey at all so
that we stop the activity of all the
Smugglers
so that is also related to cooperation
with third third countries and speeding
up the process of returns
and we of course supported the European
migration pact Provisions but we also
rejected any mandatory quotas when it
comes to redistribution of refugees in
the Czech Republic we think it's
inhumane and it doesn't work
we also
talked
about uh potential ways to support the
countries that have to face the huge
wave of Ukrainian refugees
and I am happy that the president
perceives that as a huge challenge not
only for our society but also for others
central European societies and I'm happy
that she's ready to help us and search
for other ways to support us and help us
let me also mention Euro seven yeah
because that's another topic that we
talked about briefly
the Czech Republic played a very
important role in negotiating the review
of Euro seven
of what it should look like in the end
we tried to assess the impact of Hero 7
on the Czech industry and that's why we
promoted a moderate wording of that
regulation that would help us
effectively cooperate create a group of
like-minded countries
and uh
through all these means we managed to
achieve a reasonable review of that
standard and I think it will be for the
benefit of everybody and we also
discussed one more good news but I'll
leave it up to the president to tell you
about it
and we touched on one more issue
which is important for the Czech
Republic and that's the support of
Czechs and Czech citizens in European
Union institutions and bodies uh thanks
to other debates with the president and
support on her side we achieved certain
success
recently mainly when it comes to having
Czech citizens in high positions in the
EU institutions and we'd like to
continue in these efforts and I'm happy
that the president's team is working
with our team to create a special action
plan for that and I believe it will
bring more beneficial outcomes when it
comes to check representation in the EU
I think it is important for the Czech
public so that people see that our
people have their place in European
institutions it also helps them to
better accept what is happening in
Brussels
thank you and let me give the floor to
Madam president instead better thank you
for the warm welcome and for the good
discussions
um indeed congratulations to the fact
that to check
staff members have been promoted now to
Senior Management
this shows the continuation of our
excellent work and cooperation during
the Czech presidency of the council
a big success for czechia and
um I also you mentioned the Euro seven
decision yesterday congratulations thank
you for your leadership in shaping good
compromise which is a solid one and I
think we can move on the basis of this
con um compromise so thank you very much
for the role check your played
um thanks to the many successes of your
presidency we have also made huge
progress in the meantime on strategic
files and I wanted to mention two of
them the first is your rock solid
support to Ukraine
since day one of Russia's brutal
Invasion be it through the successive
ways of sanctions against Russia or our
financial support packages for Ukraine
all of this has been instrumental in
helping Ukraine successfully resist the
invasion keeping the Ukrainian State
running and preparing for reconstruction
and I know that czechia as a whole is
standing by the brave Ukrainian Nation
Czech people have been welcoming those
fleeing the war with open arms
this generosity honors your country
Europe will be forever grateful
and another success of your presidency
concerns the energy transition
first and foremost repower EU repower EU
is Europe's roadmap to energy
Independence as a response to the energy
crisis Unleashed by Russia and indeed I
am very glad to announce that we have
approved today
your revised Next Generation EU plan
including the new repower EU chapter
the revised plan brings now 2.2 billion
euros in additional funding for czechia
this includes
736 million euros under repower EU
as investments in stronger electricity
grid more renewable energy of course
Energy Efficiency very important also
clean transport
and also very important the skills
needed to succeed in the industrial
transition so a good package of 2.2
billion
the green transition is a necessity as
much as an opportunity and this is the
path we have chosen to take together as
a union
nevertheless very important the choice
of the energy mix is and will remain a
national prerogative
we know that nuclear plays a central
role in checkers Energy System
and that it will continue to require
investment
to play its role in the Czech energy
transition
and this is why we are always willing to
consider state aid of course provided
the conditions are right but this is
important
and this is also why we support
cutting-edge nuclear technology under
our Net Zero industry act to boost
innovation
and cross-border cooperation
and yes we also discussed migration and
I can can underline what you've said
prime minister dear Peter this is a
phenomenon that concerns the whole of
Europe and it needs a European response
including here in czechia
we want indeed to support member states
in managing migration effectively and
humanely
we are going to see how we can check
check help check here in this context
in particular
because you have welcomed Ukrainian
refugee
we have proposed a very targeted
increase of 15 billion euros
specifically
to help member states manage migration
like for example check here this is
these 15 billion is part of our proposed
revision of the so-called multi-annual
EU budget
we of course open to discussing
potential improvements to our proposal
But ultimately our support to check in
other member states depends on our
capacity to agree on the revision of the
EU budget otherwise there simply won't
be enough funding available and
therefore I'm very grateful that I know
I can count on check your support in
driving forward the discussion in a
constructive manner so thank you very
much again for hosting me here I'm very
much looking forward to see you next
week at the European Council in Granada
thank you very much
thank you and have a nice evening have a
nice afternoon
[Music]